[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui oui
je vais pas m j'ai déjà la fin de
l'émission les chéris vous le saurez
vertus leur touche pas pourquoi ce
débrief médias et danse on a également
une personne au téléphone qui valent
soirée contre caux et cette personne
c'est que sa fille était avec nous tu as
attendu de saint ciers
alors oui que sa fille était toujours là
ouais je suis toujours là ça fait quand
même deux plombes du mal et n'diaye qui
sait tous préféré dans l'équipe
jahan foot à me taper la pub il échange
on nous appelait pourquoi tu énervé
comme ça tu t'es fait larguer par tam un
fou quoi je suis gay
[Rires]
alors comme les chapelles confiance et
matt que les surstocks lancé ça peut
être pas à quel bac elle c'est plutôt
mon amoureux du moment
ah ouais mon amoureux du moment un oued
ouais pourquoi c'est qu'hier saffier
away d'accord saffier tepa sur m6 ou
france un vrai oui oui à renter une
heure oui en direct pour le spectacle
ouais exactement ses gardes
[Applaudissements]